thierry beccaro c'est vrai que vous avez
livré un témoignage bouleversant vous le
7 mai dernier
dans votre livre je suis né à 17 ans et
vous parler notamment des violences que
votre père vous faisait subir
ouais et c'est vrai que quand vous voyez
des affaires comme ça de famille va se
trouve que moi moi j'ai fait j'ai
témoigné après va pas rester silencieux
pendant bien bien des années mais je ne
suis pas passé parce par ce chemin que
qui me semble être un chemin très très
compliqué on passe par des méandres un
petit peu nauséabondes je suis pas
certain que ça serve la protection de
l'enfance
avec tout ça est très très compliqué moi
ce que je sais que ce livre que j'ai
écrit
si vous le lisez attentivement il n'y a
pas d'accusation
non je ne porte pas de jugement j'ai
fait tout un travail justement puisqu'on
parle de psychiatrie moi je suis allé
sur le divan j'ai eu ce courage parce
qu'il faut le lui faut du courage pour
le faire
j'ai eu du courage et j'ai travaillé
pour essayer d'aller mieux moi même pour
moi et pour les autres c'est ça
s'apprend dès alors vous dites notamment
dans votre livre parce que je voudrais
citer les spectres téléspectateurs qui
n'ont pas encore lu lead que votre père
dès qu'il est sous l'emprise de l'alcool
ce qui est très fréquent le moindre
prétexte une note un regard ou un geste
suffit pour entraîner un véritable
déluge de gifles et de coups dont le dos
le plus souvent parfois sur d'autres
parties du corps ouais ça sert mais le
paradoxe de cette de ce que je raconte
dans ce livre ce qui était terrible
c'est que mon père était comme jeudi
était aussi un mec formidable formidable
qui avait un charme fou il ressemblait à
don diego de la vega un cd v les oraux
et il avait ses démons il avait ses
démons et gm j'ai compris pourquoi il
était passé par là alors pardonné comme
j'ai réussi à le faire ça veut pas dire
où il avait pardonné à votre père oui
j'ai le jeu le jeu les accompagner avec
ma soeur on est allé au bout avec lui ça
veut pas dire qu'on oublie mais ça veut
dire qu'on passe dans une autre
dimension qui n'est pas celle de la
rancoeur pas de l'amertume qui vous
empêchent d'avancer car je pense avoir
fait un joli parcours bien sûr donc
c'est là qu'on peut prononcer le mot de
résilience dit
au delà de la violence physique la
détresse psychologique est tout aussi
difficile à vivre
il n'est pas rare qu après les coups mon
père vienne me voir dans ma chambre pour
m'embrasser
dire qu'il m'aime alors ça c'était
c'était dévastateur parce que je
comprenais plus rien quoi gt gt tout
minot évidemment donc je me disais mais
s'il vient de dire qui même c'est que
c'est que j'ai rien fait parce que les
enfants ils comprennent pas ils n'ont
pas là la structure psychologique pour
comprendre ce qui se passe et pourquoi
on leur fait ça donc et b même quand
j'ai écrit le livre j'ai eu du mal à
employer certains bout parce qu'on
continue on continue malgré tout à
protéger ses parents hésitent c'était
compliqué mais on n'est pas au stade de
ce qui se passe en ce moment dans la
famille moix vous dit si j'ai décidé de
me livrer à travers ce témoignage c'est
avant tout pour tenter de rompre
l'insupportable silence autour des
souffrances dont sont encore victimes
trop d'enfants je vous encourager les
victimes à libérer leurs propres paroles
ne pas agir ne pas parler alors que l'on
soupçonne quelque chose vous rend de
facto complice et vous dit aussi qu'à
une voisine qui a probablement deviné ce
qui se passait chez vous assez des
enfants soyez sages ce soir c'est votre
père qui vous garde ça c'était risquer
c'était quoi cette histoire
hc c'était une femme on est dans les
années 60 ha ouais attention il n'y a
pas deux il n'y a pas de cellule
psychologique il n'y a pas de dope si on
va chez des psys si on les fout et cette
femme bon bah voilà
elle est douce se doutait bien que comme
ma mère avait des vacations puisqu'elle
était militaire elle travaille elle
soirée quand elle travaillait soir c'est
mon père qui arrivaient pour nous garder
donc cette phrase qui résonne encore
dans ma tête c'était terrible
faites attention attention cyril parce
que ce soir c'est intel qui vient là sur
le cateau c'est ton patron j'ai ça c'est
votre père qui il ait la garde d'enfants
elle avait peur pour vous c'était
terrible non c'était c'était une façon
de ces c'était comme une espèce de 2-2-2
devenant qu'on vous qu'on vous qu'on
vous met dans les veines quoi genre j'ai
commencé à flipper quoi est-ce que je
n'avais pas quand est-ce que vous allez
tomber espèce d'épée de damoclès ça
pouvait tomber n'importe quand pour un
oui pour un non et un moment votre père
il est quand il était bien c'était
formidable sinatra dean martin georges
brassens gp plein de choses avec nous
c'est une main c'est que c'est c'est
grâce à ça que vous avez enfin grâce à
cause de ça que vous avez voulu être
dans le divertissement divertir les gens
j'ai toujours eu oui ça alors là dessus
j'ai je me suis toujours dit ce qui
t'arrive sa salade ça n'intéresse pas
les gens maintenant sers-toi de ce que
tu as vécu
pour donner du plaisir aux gens donnent
lors de la bonne humeur
il est poli d'être gay c'est ce que
j'écris dans le temps assez salé dans le
livre et puis après ça tu fait tout le
travail pour pour essayer d'aller mieux
et puis voilà depuis je suis avec
l'unicef je suis devenu ambassadeur
bien sûr c'est une aventure incroyable
et je remercie tout le monde d'ailleurs
parce que c est vous avez mine de rien
j'ai l'impression quand on vous en
parlait regardez quand même un beau
souvenir de votre de votre père une
orestie terre que vous essayez de garder
que les bons moments mais oui oui c'est
ce que j'ai appris quand j'étais sur le
divan ouais parce que le loppsi dont je
parle d'être dans le livre et que j'ai
pu j'ai de temps en temps en ligne me
disait vous savez l'analyse s'est pas
uniquement pour parler des nuages et du
ciel gris il faut essayer de se souvenir
aussi de des moments il ya eu du soleil
et ça c'était important
c'était important de lui en voulait pas
du tout aujourd'hui non non non non non
pas du jeu
je pense que c'est s'est dit aussi dans
le livre un moment donné je dis c'est un
paradoxe
merci maman merci papa parce que ce
chemin qui nous fait parcourir et pas
m'a fait découvrir la poésie la musique
ggg j'ai traversé des des moments
incroyables je vous avez des enfants
vous tient trois enfants trois enfants
comment elle a été la relation avec je
n'ai jamais que je n'ai jamais touché
bien sûr 1 alors que j'ai eu tellement
peur est le menteur d'être papa parce
que qu'est-ce qu'est ce qu'on craint le
plus c'est la fameuse répétition bien
sûr et c'est pas une fatalité
ça n'est pas une fatalité on peut avoir
subi des violences et on peut être un
papa formidable et aimait ses enfants et
on peut y arriver quoi c'est
[Applaudissements]